bonsoir allez tire habitants de vous
retrouver vous allez braves y est brave
et un paris voilà vous voilà enfin ce
plateau à ma grande joie donc à trois
mois depuis l'inde la présidentielle
cette visite dans le sud de la france
sur le thème de la sécurité quel est le
but y'a affiche évidemment il ya un
petit peu de cash et quand même pas le
but affiché c'est comme incroyable ce
président qui n'est pas candidat mais
qui est un candidat perpétuel là il fait
des promesses de 15 milliards sur cinq
ans comme s'il était déjà réélu comme
s'il n'y avait pas d'élections et
pourtant d'où vient ce plan alors il ya
bien sûr eu le beauvau de la sécurité il
est sur les terres dans le sud à nice
accueilli par christian estrosi ancien
élève qui est maintenant chez horizon
clairement pour draguer cet électorat là
pour aller chasser là où les
républicains sont forts sur les thèmes
aussi qu'ils sont les thèmes de
prédilection des républicains le
régalien la sécurité et on voit bien que
il dit il passe son temps en fait à
chercher où sont les voir et à empêcher
ses opposants finalement d'exister en
préemptant leur sujet avec la force de
frappe d'un président de la république
les moyens de la présidence de la
république donc le jeu est totalement
inégal et ce candidat qui n'est pas
déclarée est évidemment officiellement
candidat même s'il ne dit pas que c'est
officiel quand on voit ces déclarations
aujourd'hui à l'adresse de la police et
sur la sécurité est évidemment lexine
moyen pour lui de chasser sur les terres
traditionnellement à droite un à l'air
évidemment les thèmes clés et se
positionner en force dans le match et
creysse macro oui bien sûr puisque
valérie pécresse
l'ancien campagne et a bien du mal à
exister en train eric zemmour qui avait
capté toute l'attention médiatique
lorsqu'il a lancé sa campagne est elle
qui a commencé à parler du régalien en
descendant la cave pour aller chercher
le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy même si on
dit c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
il faudrait trouver d'autres sujets mais
elle a parlé bien entendu des centres de
rétention de la façon dont aussi la
police était un point faible de ce
quinquennat la sécurité des français on
a vu emmanuel macron absents sur ces
sujets là pendant cinq ans et il se
réveille à marseille d'abord et puis
maintenant pour voir colmater toutes les
brèches finalement d'une candidature ou
le bilan est calamiteux en matière de
sécurité en matière de police et des
promesses c'est le beauvau c'est les
premiers sur une réélection il parle
comme si cet argent c'était le sien non
c'est le nôtre c'est un plan aussi qui
sera implémentée par peu importe qui
prendra la suite à l'elysée mais on voit
bien qu'il n'y avait pas d'intérêt sur
ces sujets là et il a fallu du temps
pour que mma qu'on comprenne que c'était
un sujet important pour les français
d'amérique se tient s'en est donné à
coeur joie beaucoup à droite 1 mais n'a
pas cadré et c'est normal si valérie
pécresse veut vraiment existé dans cette
campagne elle doit se démarquer des
meules macron puisqu'un de ses points
faibles c'est d'être trop proche sur
l'europe sur aussi l'économie sur plein
de sujets où on pourrait dire mais
quelle est la différence alors s'il ya
un sujet là où on peut le faire c'est la
fois sur l'immigration sur la sécurité
des thèmes classiques de la droite
sachant bien sûr qu'il ya des outsiders
comme eric zemmour qui peuvent déborder
à droite eric ciotti a boycotté la
visite officielle du président alors
qu'il ya normalement un accueil
républicain des élus cas que le
président parce que l'eau aujourd'hui
les républicains doivent être dans une
opposition frontale au chef de l'état
pour exister or ils ne le sont pas sur
le pass vaccinale on le voit à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont voté alors
en ordre dispersé avec certains qui sont
partis comme guillaume pelletier au
sénat on a entendu monsieur retailleau
ce matin dans un entretien aux échos
d'hier que le groupe l'est républicain
votre a majoritairement avec quelques
amendements pour le pass vaccinale or là
c'était une occasion en or pour embêter
empêcher emmanuel macron et se démarquer
et le régalien c'est évidemment alexis
est également un thème fort de marine le
pen la candidate qui multiplie les
déplacements y at il à un embouteillage
à droite sur sur ce thème sur le thème
de la sécurité non il y en a jamais
assez en fit dire à droite et puis c'est
50 nuance de droite vous avez
différentes façon d aborder et c'est
vrai que c'est assez étonnant de voir
marine le pen qui avait été un peu
fébriles un peu inquiétés lors du
lancement de la campagne d'eric zemmour
finalement retomber sur ses pattes et se
dire de manière assez olympienne moi je
sais ce que c'est qu'une campagne
présidentielle j'ai mes déplacements de
prévu j'ai mon équipe qui est en place
si j'ai des thématiques j'ai la
confiance aussi des français qui me
connaissent eric zemmour a certes
récupéré une signature comme celle de de
guillaume pelletier mais ça pèse peu
comparé à la personnalité qui est marine
le pen dans le personnage politique dans
le paysage politique donc on voit bien
que healy a finalement de la place pour
tout le monde sur cette thématique
d'autant plus qu'ils monnayent macro est
en train d'essayer de jouer de diviser
c'est d'autant plus facile film allemand
de dire sur ce bilan calamiteux nous
nous avons des solutions et autre chose
il faut passer maintenant à autre chose
et pour finir alexis loin de ces thèmes
est dans une toute autre problématique
car la gauche qui semble décidément
bloqué dans une bulle par les multiples
candidatures quelle issue possible on se
pose la question oui alors c'est
extrêmement étonnant parce qu'on est à
trois mois d'une élection majeure la
présidentielle et les candidats de
gauche sont enfermés dans une bulle dans
l'impression qu'ils sont pas chez nous
ils sont pas avec nous ils ne parlent
que d'eux qui s'en va qui vient qui fait
cette primaire populaire qui est la
primaire de christiane taubira dirons
nous anne hidalgo qui ne s'est pas
célibat bon alors il y en a qui arrêtent
et je crois on ne l'a pas revu depuis la
rentrée c'est arnaud montebourg mais
yannick jadot parlait du temple solaire
en disant que les leaders de gauche sont
en train de se sacrifier sur l'autel de
la désunion et puis jean luc mélenchon
lui a décidé de regarder ça de or il est
déjà un peu l'un pierre ouzeau moi ça
fait un an que je fais campagne j'ai des
meetings j'ai un programme venez si vous
voulez j'ai autre chose à faire parce
qu'on est à trois mois d'élections donc
c'est lunaire en fait de voir la gauche
qui clairement abandonné l'idée d'être
au second tour de cette campagne
président sortant
s'il ya une issue favorable je pense que
c'est derrière jean-luc mélenchon qui
est haut dans les sondages et qui
d'ailleurs conforte cette avance est
maintenant libre aux leaders de gauche
de le rejoindre ou non mais c'est
ridicule de vouloir faire un vote à
trois mois d'un vote majeur sachant que
la campagne est là la dynamique est là
au sein des troupes insoumise et que le
programme met tout le monde d'accord y
compris les écologistes tout comme le
parti socialiste donc un peu de sérieux
à gauche maintenant il y à une
candidature qui sort du lot il faut
l'admettre c'est celle de jean luc
mélenchon map qu'ils ont du mal à
l'admettre va falloir peut-être sortir
de la bulle en tirer les conséquences
peut-être pour merci en tout cas avec
six poulains d'avoir été avec nous